week one is in the books yeah there you
go you ready for this i want to just
talk about the demonstrations i don't
call them protests
because they're demonstrations more than
they are protests at this point so what
was your take on what some of the
players
and teams and organizations did uh
during
the national anthem and prior to the
kickoff of uh sundays and even
thursday's game
well one thing michael that i always
think about with the nfl is that
compared to baseball compared to the nba
they are the weakest union and the least
empowered out of all of our professional
athletes so anything that they managed
to get done
is impressive and the president was set
this summer when deshaun watson
uh and pat mahomes put together that
video and basically put the nfl in all
notices like yeah we're your highest
paid players
we're the face of the league and we
think something needs to be done
uh you know so thursday's game with the
texans and the chiefs
where look i knew the shoes were gonna
win but the fact that you had people
booing you had fans and i use that term
generously booing at players simply
locking arms is a reminder in case we
didn't know
uh that this was never about how or or
what people were protesting it was just
a bunch of people saying
you know shut up black folk we don't
want to hear about your issues you're
there to entertain and die for us
essentially and so
i was pleased to see the number of
players
who did some sort of demonstration one
way or another i think it'll be
interesting to see if
it's anything more than lip service look
the nfl if they actually gave a crap
about black lives
they would do something about how many
off-duty police officers they hire
what kind of training is expected of
them you know nfl owners are basically
mini trumps in the cities and states
that they're in
they could have a real influence on
black lives voting access
health care all sorts of critical issues
to their own
employees if they cared about it so i'll
be interested to see how much is done
above and beyond these players putting
essentially their careers on a line to
take a knee
which wasn't even possible for them two
years ago
you know jason one of the reasons that
players
across all sports are protesting because
of police violence
including the brianna briana taylor and
louisville today there was a settlement
between louisville
and the family 12 million dollars police
reforms along with that
you know you watched that you know we
began the show
uh talking about it the impact of it who
she was humanizing her um
just just you watched that today what
did you think
of of the settlement and some of the
commentary around the settlement
um i was extremely disappointed
uh whenever you have to think of death
in terms of what it's worth
12 million dollars is nothing her mother
her sisters
her loved ones are never going to hear
her voice again they're never going to
hear her laugh we've passed her birthday
um we still don't have any indictments
of the men who killed her um we have
a state attorney uh a general who's
basically
sat on his fingers the whole time um and
we also have a situation
this cannot be overlooked when we're
talking about brianna taylor
it shows once again that even the blue
wall
of silence etc etc doesn't extend
to black people she was an emt a former
emt
she was part of that collection of
firemen cops and emts
that protect the public so you can still
be a part
of public safety in america and be
murdered as a black person
and what they'll do is give you two
barrels of syrup which is essentially
what this amounts to
so i'm not happy about this result i'm
extremely sad
and i think it's important lest anybody
out there criticize because there's
always somebody out there who wants to
be critical
when settlements are made in these kinds
of cases
it is because the family and the
families legal team has looked at every
single legal avenue and recognizes
that the structural racism both the
individuals and the
the legal systems in place would make it
almost impossible to get justice and
that's the most disappointing thing
you settle because you know there's but
so far you go you settle because you
know
in kentucky they're gonna fight tooth
and nail they're gonna push against an
indictment they're not going to hold
these cops accountable
and that's the part that's most
disturbing and also important to
remember for everybody out there who
cares about small government
conservatives et cetera et cetera you
know that 12 million dollars is coming
from somewhere right
it comes from the insurance fund that
the police pay into which eventually
trickles down to the taxpayer so i hope
the people in louisville
are happy about the fact that they are
funding paying off a family
for the woman that the cops shot
they're paying for that the taxpayers
are paying
to silence a family after their police
officers murdered her so
that's i'm never happy with these kind
of settlements and certainly not in a
situation where brianna taylor
i don't care what kind of reforms they
say they're going to have the reforms
need to start
with actual punishment anything other
than that and it's an embarrassment and
a reminder of the white supremacy we
live under
no definitely well said i mean listen
history has taught us in general
not to believe that the the criminal
justice system they
are designed to serve us so it can't
fail us so i won't say it's gonna fail
but
that we won't get justice through the
criminal justice system specifically as
it relates to louisville the state of
kentucky we know that
the attorney general is in the pocket of
the gop you know he's joined at the hip
of mitch mcconnell and
and again for hopefully another 40
whatever days
the sitting president um but it sounds
like jason it sounds like you're pretty
resigned
to the likelihood that
the family and by by accessing those of
us who grieve with with the taylor with
brianna saylor's family
that we had to tell the family that we
won't get both that we won't get
financial restitution
as well as substantial charges let alone
a conviction
from the criminal justice system this is
where it ends from in your in your
expert opinion
very likely because you know the
attorney general cameron who trump name
dropped as a potential
uh uh you know supreme court nominee
good lord if you think clarence thomas
is bad
just imagine cameron again who's
stunting on the gram with his new
fiancee
uh while a woman has been dead and
buried murdered by state-sponsored
violence
once these once these payoffs are made
once settlements are made
it is very unlikely that the public
pressure will be enough
to force the state attorney general to
pursue charges
we've seen local attorney generals
it doesn't have to be an either or i
mean the woman was murdered in her
own home and then they tried to throw
her boyfriend in jail for defending him
shooting a warning shot it's always
amazing to me that the man whose house
was broken into
can figure out how to shoot a warning
shot but trained police officers
couldn't
they had to empty the clip you know so
yeah i'm concerned that there will be no
further pursuit just like we saw
uh in ferguson just like we've seen in
charleston south carolina just like we
might see in kenosha and just like we
see in minneapolis
there's not look there's a difference
between
retribution and justice right we may get
some retribution from the standpoint of
having people pay but justice
is when people have to face the
consequences of their actions
and somebody else some insurance company
paying uh
paying your bills for murder that ain't
justice
you know jason there could be even more
payments
coming because if you think about it the
way the raw the laws are written in
kentucky
because of that warning shot by her
boyfriend
if they fired those police officers they
can say well wait a minute this is
i have the right to fire because i'm
defending myself so if they fire them
they can sue
and they can get money i mean think
about that
yeah let me tell you something one thing
i'm the most pro-union person
that you're gonna empower like as i
started by
we started discussion of football we'll
be talking about you know the important
sort of players unions and everything
else like that
but police unions are out of
control and that's why they can do
things like that
that's why they have 30 day windows
before they can be asked any questions
in investigation
that's why they can be covered and i've
said this all along because of racism in
this country
because only recently have we had the
sort of
public pushes for reform that we need
police
are public servants who get to behave in
a way that nobody else does
and we have plenty of public servants we
have emts we have teachers i i'm you
know i work in baltimore
and i remember saying at the time of
freddie gray and how much the police
union got involved in and marilyn mosby
tried her best
but i mean she was fighting against the
system it was almost impossible to sort
of dig your way through
i was like if i was a public school
teacher and i took 20 kids on a field
trip
and came back with 17. i'm going to jail
there's no i couldn't sit there and tell
a jury hey it was a rough ride
three sixth graders died and that's
essentially what the cops were able to
do
and then justify it and their union back
them and all too often when police are
fired as you mentioned they are fired
the union fights on their behalf to
bring their jobs back and i think
one slightly positive thing that's
happened in some of these protests
during this pandemic
is that you've seen it in north carolina
you've seen in different parts of new
york
there have been massive resignations of
police
and i think that's good because if the
idea of reform makes you think you can't
do your job
then get the heck out of the job and
i'll put this out there i've said i
wrote a whole piece about this for the
grill i'm in favor of defunding the
police
i mean you the way the policing works is
dysfunctional anyway it's like having a
bad restaurant people keep getting sick
at that restaurant
i don't care how many times you say
under new management you tear it down
you build something new
what we're expecting police officers to
do with military training
we want them to be child care providers
health care providers and protect the
public it doesn't work
we're sending good money after bad uh
and i hope that changes in a lot more
cities
let police do policing and recreate a
system that actually provides public
service and public support
i hope and i hope that we flip off a lot
of clips and i'm sure this interview
will be one of them that we share on
social that is as concise and
explanation
as you can ask for it i hope people when
they here defund the police they take
offense to it
understand what exactly that means what
exactly that different the police
movement is about and
dr jason johnson as usual breaking it
down
as well as anybody can uh breaking it
down so it could forever
and consistently be broke my brother
listen
this hopefully it's the first of many
visits to brother from another man
you'll come through again good yeah i
would definitely come through
uh i got i got plenty of obnoxious
sports takes i'm on that first week over
reaction
high because my seahawks actually let
russ kick so you know i'm ready to go
okay well you know what we about to talk
about russell uh russell wilson in a
little while man so
that's right we'll enjoy that
conversation we'll give him some love
later on in the show but that's what's
up man i appreciate you thank you so
much for following through
anytime
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports